theoretically many experts may tell you
a recession is the worst time to start a
business but i'm going to give you 10
reasons why this is the perfect time for
you to start a
[Music]
business stick around to the very end
i'm going to give you a pdf with all the
notes from today's content and if you
get value from the video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
having said that pruning season is here
which means five things happen during
the recession at market crash number one
bad companies go out of business number
two it creates room for new companies to
grow number three starts a decade or so
of growth number four no more overpriced
talent and number five access to talent
previously unavailable these five things
are great opportunities for new
businesses small businesses and
entrepreneurs so now 10 reasons why this
is a great time to start a business for
yourself number one when a season like
this show up unfortunately many people
don't make it which means there is less
competition any time there's less
competition if you got a better story
you're able to get in front of customers
better so again point number one during
the recession there is less competition
bigger opportunity for you if you can
survive and thrive during this type of a
season point number two all-in mentality
unfortunately unfortunately when times
like this comes up recession market
crash backs against the wall people
don't have a choice but to be all in
because they have to pay the bills they
have to survive they have to fight there
is no choice so a a climate like this
attracts a team of people that are
willing to say let's roll up the slaves
listen man this ain't good times we got
to go out there and fight and everybody
has a higher all-in mentality during the
season like this than when it's a
perfect season point number three access
to good talent so when the market turns
and it's kind of like it is today good
talent gets fired amazon just laid off
180 000 people banks are letting people
go up facebook's not hiring people right
now google's telling people you better
come in or else a lot of companies are
letting go of people this is not like
they're getting rid of their bad people
they're just getting rid of people
because they have to get rid of people
what does that mean to you talent is out
there and typically at a lower cost than
it was before when the market was great
so for a startup or a new business you
can get talent at a reasonable price
today that you couldn't get a year two
years ago point number four everything
is cheaper today when it comes onto
vendors for example
if you want to get office space today
there's plenty of office space plenty of
markets so you can get typically
discounted when the market is a little
bit you know uncertain about what's
going to be happening vendors less
customers they need business they're
willing to talk to you for me i started
my insurance company in 2009 i'll never
forget the meeting i had with aig i'm
having a meeting with aig they got 20
executives sitting that fly out to their
office in houston
and they're all sitting there and every
second of the day the news is talking
about aig's going out of business and me
i need a contract with an insurance
carrier so i'm sitting in a corner at
the table by myself everybody's sitting
around i'm writing stuff on the board
trying to get them to do business with
me
finally one of the guys says listen
let's just face it
we need someone right now to ride our
business because people don't want to
write aig and you need somebody that
gives you a contract we think we got a
perfect marriage and he was right they
gave me a contract because nobody else
was giving it to me i was a smaller
company newer company and they needed
somebody to write their business and we
were willing to do it it became a
perfect match we got the opportunity
they got the win everybody moved on but
if the market was great that may have
not happened point number five it takes
a downturn to find out who's real and
who's not the reality of it is when i
was saying this is a pruning season we
don't really know who's real and who's
not we don't really know who's tough and
who's not running a business is very
very very hard don't let anybody fool
you for every one person that makes it
98 go out of business just keep that
that in mind it's not like one of these
things where everybody goes out there
and does it so for you if you're sitting
there saying man i don't know if i want
to go out there and start a business no
problem go find somebody that isn't team
up with them but the reality of it is if
you are somebody that's not afraid of
hard work if you are somebody with a
real vision if you are somebody that's
willing to pay the price this is the
perfect season for you point number six
it takes times like this to reveal the
real disrupters by the way what do i
mean by this when season is like this
and everybody is scared and things are
breaking you're able to see if i was
running it that way i would have done
this ooh if i had done i would have done
it this what if we did it this way oh
what if we did it that way this is a
like for example education we had a
podcast that we did on education today
and the whole conversation was if all
these things are broken today what if
somebody actually produced a great
university where you truly wanted your
kids to go there because when people
came out of that school they were
stronger they were leaders that were
doing great you would want them to go on
their right well it takes an economy
like this a climate like this for
education and universities that are
getting called that left and right for
somebody to come and disrupt it so for
you whatever industry it may be you may
be looking at an industry saying i would
have done it in a very different way
this is a perfect season for disruptors
to be born if that's you perfect time
for you point number seven cheaper
equipment due to more bankruptcies shot
a friend of mine that one day this is in
2008 all of a sudden he says pat take a
look at the gym i just bought i said
what are you talking about come take a
look at my gym i go to his place he's
got
unbelievable equipment the guy prior to
him bought this gym he bought
state-of-the-art equipment spent like a
half a million dollars for this massive
gym he came he bought it pennies on the
dollar i think he spent less than like
80 000 on the equipment all in house the
equipment was only used for three or
four years he took it over why because
there's a lot of discounts right now for
people that couldn't build it couldn't
make it in business we just want to look
at a property right 150 000 square foot
building that we may make an offer on or
not and they're asking here's what we're
asking here's what we're asking i said
listen i'll make a cash out for 22
million dollars right now if you want to
i'm like well there's no way we're going
to be doing that no problem it's okay
because i don't need this building but
i'll make a cash offer of 22 million
point is everything is discounted during
times like this so if you are starting a
business you don't have to buy buy
things at full price things are
discounted by others who weren't good
operators and the market doesn't favor
good operators the whole concept of this
is somebody makes up a path isn't that
kind of cold it's not i learned very
quickly when i went to summer league to
see if i can play for my basketball team
even though i'm six four six five by the
time it was done guess what i was not
ready and they didn't put me on the team
as big as i was as tall as i was as fast
as i was i did not make it it was a
pruning process that means i'm not meant
to be a basketball player just like a
lot of people are not meant to be
operators everybody can go out there and
find out if they're an operator if you
do if you have the cuts and courage and
you say i'm gonna do it or you're gonna
partner with somebody this is a good
time
and things will be discounted that's
just the reality of it number eight
investors have fewer opportunities to
invest in what does this mean when again
pruning season comes in and a lot of
people don't make it investors don't
have a lot of opportunities because not
a lot of people are starting businesses
during that time you know just a year
and a half ago you can invest 100
million in this 5 million in this 2
million and this a million in this a
half a million in this there aren't that
many opportunities during downturns
which if you are somebody that's putting
up numbers during a season like this it
is a lot easier to get the attention of
investors today then maybe you would
have gotten two years ago in a great
market point number nine incumbents
became lazy what do i mean by this if
you're getting into a marketplace and
say somebody went on a seven year run
and the company grew their business is
doing very very well typically success
makes people lazy unfortunately a lot of
times people are saying like oh my god
look how we're doing look how much money
i'm making they golf six days a week
they go off five days a week they sleep
in they go home earlier most people
compete that way so when you do come in
and you choose to compete you're making
them work listen to me i'm gonna give
you something a little bit of an insight
nothing is more exciting as a competitor
when i make my competitors work it's so
awesome when you do that when your
competitor sits there and they're like
man i've been free for the last five
years no one's been saying anything to
me i've been sleeping in i've been
kicking back i've been drinking i've
been partying what the hell is this new
business dude making me go to work they
don't like that this is an opportunity
for you to make them go to work because
quite frankly a lot of people haven't
been working
for a long time they've just been acting
like it so the success makes it seem
like they're working they have not been
working you come in you're not afraid of
work you see blind spots perfect
opportunity for you to go out and do
something with your business point
number 10 the opportunity to stretch a
dollar so what does this really mean if
you're born in a wealthy family and the
family is rich it's like how much is
this thing 800 bucks i'll take it right
but if you're born in a poor family and
somebody says how much is this thing 800
800
yeah why
i can only afford to give you 450. 4.50
yeah i can't give it to you for 450. man
i can't do nothing about that's all i
got i'll give it to you for 6.50 nope
most i can go is 550. all right whatever
take it at 550. see the guy that's got
money would have taken it at 800 but the
guy that doesn't have money and is
trying to stretch the dollar just save
250 when you start a company everybody
who's part of that startup
learns how to stretch the dollar in
every possible way your competitors that
have been around for a while with a lot
of cash and bank account they don't know
how to stretch the dollar that's an edge
for you i was straight up with you if
you got value from today's video give it
a thumbs up subscribe to the channel if
you want the pdf click here to get the
pdf and if you want to watch another
video i highly recommend you watching
during the season like this it's called
grand master entrepreneur it's a speech
i give in long beach a few years ago
click here to watch that video take care
everybody bye
[Music]